promotions into the top ranks of the US
military have been blocked for months
now by one Republican senator in
particular that's Alabama's Tommy
tuberville who objects to a pentagon
policy maintaining abortion access for
service members the Secretary of Defense
and response says that the Senator's
move creates a quote clear risk to
military Readiness David Martin has more
they volunteered to wear the uniform in
this country they volunteered to risk
their lives for this country why do they
deserve to be punished Senator Tim Kaine
of Virginia became the latest Democrat
to castigate Republican senator Tommy
tuberville for the hold he has placed on
senior military promotions what would it
take for you to lift your hold on all
these nominations all they need to do is
change it back to where it was
tuberville is demanding defense
secretary Lloyd Austin rescind this memo
authorizing paid leave and
transportation costs for service members
to travel to states where abortion is
legal
so far tuberville has blocked more than
250 promotions some of them to Major
commands around the world as well as
heads of the armed services aren't you
dragging the military into politics I
want to keep politics out of military it
is ruining our military General c.q
Brown President Biden's nominee to
become the next chairman of the Joint
Chiefs warned of the consequences this
hole could have it has an impact not
just for the senior officer but you know
all their staff and all those below them
we will lose talent because of those
those challenges but tuberville says he
won't back down by the end of the year
650 officers could be held back from
promotion and the senator has also come
under Fire for recent comments labeling
white nationalists simply Americans
remarks he now disavows I'm totally
against white nationalism I'm totally
against it's racist okay we don't need
that in the military so white
nationalists are unfit for service they
should not be in our military for CBS
mornings I'm David Martin at the
Pentagon